It is time to play
Commercial Failure:
Tokyo Drift.
(cheering)
Oh, wow.
American celebrities
looking to cash in on their fame
will often head to Japan to
appear in bizarre TV commercials
without having to worry about it
devaluing their image
back home.
But thanks to YouTube,
we can revisit these cash grabs
and happily devalue away.
I'm gonna show you
a Japanese advertisement
starring an American celebrity,
and for 250 points
I'm gonna need you to translate
a line from the commercial.
First up, smile enthusiast,
Tommy Lee Jones.
(speaking Japanese)
Brendon.
Suffering from
erectile dysfunction?
Ask your doctor if a teenage
Japanese girl is right for you.
It works.
Next one, how about this
little number from Nic Cage?
Oh, hi. I'm Nicolas Cage,
and this is a song for you.
♪ My favorite things,
my favorite things ♪
♪ Blue jeans,
seeing a red hair girl ♪
♪ Sweet peanut butter...
Just a... a little
back story on that--
uh, he ju... he had no idea
there was a commercial
being filmed at the time.
Just, uh...
Just went to his house
and turned it into a commercial.
Brendon.
If you have an erection that
lasts more than four hours
ask Nicolas Cage to play piano
and sing to it.
All right, points.
And sing to it?
Sing to your erection.
Right. Aah!
Uh, Carmen.
Have you ever wished that
Billy Joel had brain damage?
God damn it.
That is a fantastic joke.
Points, Carmen.
Doug Benson.
Uh, throw me the beads,
I'll show you my dick.
-I don't... They're all gone.
-You're out of beads?
-I don't have any.
-They took the beads.
-No more beads.
-I don't have any that are out.
Uh...
Next one, how about this creepy
encounter with Madonna's face?
(woman speaking Japanese)
MADONNA:
♪ Watch it throw
♪ Tears on my pillow
♪ And if there is a Christ...
Doug.
Madonna still dating
younger men.
Points.
Uh, Carmen.
The Madonna sex tape
-Peter Dinklage doesn't
want you to see. -Oh, (bleep).
Aw.